.
IT NPRINE Y
>> LET'SAT RISINLLATD SAY, TTS
HA IT TODAY WI
AFFIDAVIT.
E LAERS FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP BEA.
DITHING ABOUT
ADD HER UEL.
ABOUT ITFAD .BEI THREE-FAC
T THREE-FACED ABOUT IT
>> WHAHA TY T
SEE THE DOCUMENT.
HIS WANTUMT BECAUS
SENDANT YOU TO
ISAU POINT  OF EVIDENCEUMENT
AN ISSUEORASY'REY EA
BY FUNDRAISING EMAILS.
THAN,
THF THROOM SAYING NOTHIND WHY I
Y GOINSE OH, WO SEE , WE NEED TO
T PORTIO TDAVIT?
>> IT'EAR THAT NT RELEASE SOMET
RIGHR 'T HAVIDDO LIT WE CAN.D T
>> OH, FORE THERE'
JUDGE IS GOING TO SEE THSTBOD DO
AND WITNESSES.EAD HAVE EVEN SAIC
ME NEXTY,, IF
DIDN'T WANT TO RELEASE
HE DAYOULD B,
WE NEED TO PCT
WE NAS
STAGESAN OOIN.RLY
AND HIS ALLIESTHE CAN SENGUSE TM
THERE.
>> SPEAKING OF TRUND HIS
ALLIES, JIM, ONE O
QUESTIONS E WANT D CL INFORMATI?
MAE ERS, KASH  R TO GET HIS
ON THICLINFORMATION, EVEN TH
WAS BEING E NATIONALCHIVES.
KASH PATEL SAID LASTTH
>>ELU NOW AM
NOOFFICIALLYENTATIVE
FOR DONALD TRUMP ATHAL
AND I'M GOINOW
D I'M GOING TO BLOCK
EVERY DOCUMENT AND  TION OUXT SE
THE NSC, E MATIA
CIA, DNIL , WE NEE
BUT FORGETTING ABOU.RIALFOR HER
THE GORNMENT PIN ORDER TO AGTST
R OUBECAUSE IT'S DANGEROUS FOR
>>, ALD TO GETUT
TRUMP WANTED IT?
O  IT,
A TO PUTTRUMP'S MIPLEX PLA COMPL
O RCISSID HIS PRONOU A, ME,
MINE, AND EVERHITHOSE RENER AT
THE AG, THIS IS VERNMENT.ICALLYT
TIF BELONGS TO
HIM.
>>T.
HE S I.INE.
>>S BASICALLY 5-YEAR-OLD.
ISOY
YOU T  AWAY FROM
HICAN BEAT HIMH STATUTE.
NOHEEPOURE YOU'RE TO JAIL.INASI
>> YEAH, I DE.D E
WE CAN'T SPECULATE WHAE CUNTANP
SENSITIVE GHMEASURES HAD TO BE E
>> IF Y OF UHAD DO THIS,
WE'D ALREADY BEE.